Araudubillahi mina shaytana rajim bismillahir rahmanur raheem Allahumma salli Allah sayyidina Muhammadin wala Ali sayyidina Muhammad kama sallaita wa salamta wa barata wa rahim ta wa tarahamta ala Ibrahim wa ila al Ibrahim fil alamina inna kahamiru majid assalam alaikum wa rahmatullahi wa barakatu So now that we've completed Suratul Fateha I wanted to do a session on this idea of istiqama
which is remaining steadfast on the straight path and this is one of the major challenges of walking the path and it is something that we all probably can relate to we all as Muslims we want to do the right thing we want the straight path but we're not always able to for various different reasons and then we end up getting frustrated with ourselves
and sometimes with religion itself.
Now this is something that I have personally struggled with extensively in my life.
But then Alhamdulillah I came across some material and some perspectives that has helped me a lot.
And so I thought I would like to share that with you hoping and praying that it will do the same for you.
In Surah Al-Fateha we request Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala for guidance we say guide us towards the straight path now this verse is the essence of the Surah the initial verses they are basically building up to this one right giving us an understanding of who Allah is Alhamdulillah Rabbil Alameena Rahman Rahimaliki Aumideen
but this is it is called the prayer of all prayers.
Guide us, guidance.
Guide us through instructions, role models and then through your divine companionship.
Now the question is what exactly is Sirat al-Mustaqeen?
Allah actually defines it for us in Suratul Yaseen.
where he says and no doubt about it you should worship me for that is the straight path so ibada or ubudiya the willing submission is how Allah defines the straight path
The person who willingly submits himself or herself to Allah is the one who has found the straight path, which Alhamdulillah we all have.
But now the big question is how do we walk the path?
Because we never get to our destination by just finding the correct path.
We get to it by actually walking it, right?
So how do we walk this path?
And what is the term?
Is there a term for walking this path?
There is.
And that term is called Taqwa, which is a strong mindfulness for the presence of Allah in our lives.
Taqwa, commonly translated as piety, is essential for Abu Diyya, for attaining the ranks of servitude.
And that is exactly what we asked for when we said, Iya ka na'budu wa iya ka nasta'in It is only you we worship Again, worship being the straight path.
And it is only you we seek help from.
Ista'ana, right?
What is this method of Ista'ana?
Seeking Allah's help?
Allah explains that in Surah Al-Baqarah.
He says, Wa asta'inu bis sabri wa salat
and seek my help through patience and prayer and the same word is used astainu so we have now just solved this equation right we all desire Sirat al-Mustaqim the straight path Mustaqim as I explained earlier a path that has istaqama built into it right a path of spiritual elevation
How is that achieved?
Through Ubudiyya, willing servitude to the will of Allah.
How do we walk this path?
By developing piety, by developing Taqwa, an acute awareness of who Allah is, by establishing a connection with Him.
And how do we connect with Him?
Bisabri wassalat, through patience and through prayer.
Now we all know about the daily prayers.
But what does Sabr mean here in this context?
It means to be steadfast and consistent with our prayers.
And then the ayat continues to say, And no doubt about it, for sure, this is truly an extremely difficult task for most people.
Illa, except,
those who possess the knowledge and who possess the knowledge and the awareness of the majesty of their master.
People who have Taqwa.
So it all ultimately boils down to consistency and being steadfast, Istaqamah.
Now what is Istaqamah?
It comes from the same root word ama
That was used for Mustaqim, Saratul Mustaqim, the same root word, qama.
So istaqim means to stay firm on something.
And how do we stay firm?
Allah answers that in the Quran when He says, .
He says, establish the prayer, be firm, stay firm on your prayer, stay firm on your salat.
So Istiqamah is to establish something firmly or to be solid in something, to be firm in it.
Right?
So resilience is one of the words that is used.
Grit, some people use the word grit.
But Istiqamah is essentially the ability to stand firm and be consistent in our Iman, in our worship and our belief.
To give you sort of a visual representation from the physical world of the sister ama, think about a solid tree.
A solid tree, it stands firm even when the wind blows, right?
Even if a storm hits it, it stays its ground.
Now, the question we're trying to address is, how can we be like that?
How do we develop the ability to stay strong on this path despite the storms of our situations, of our challenges, of our environments?
So you must have noticed if you read the Quran that in many verses Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala he always mentions two things when he talks about faith.
He always couples Iman with Amal.
He couples faith with action.
So we understand that there are two parts to what we are supposed to do.
There is the inner part and then there's the outer part.
What's the inner part?
It's the belief, the iman, the faith.
Another way we can think about this in terms of ibada is that there is a worship for the heart and then there is a worship for the limbs.
The body, the tongue, the ears, the eyes.
You understand?
There are the internal Ibadat and then there are the external Ibadat.
The internal has to do with our belief system, with our Iman.
How do we think of Allah ?
How do we view Him?
How do we respond internally with the things that He has asked us to do?
and why he has asked us to do those.
That's all internal.
It has to do with our certainty or with our doubt, right?
So certainty is Yaqeen, doubt is Shaq.
So we are either certain about it or we have doubts about it.
But that all has to do with our internal mechanism, our internal worship system.
What are the external Ibadat?
Those are the obvious ones, the five time prayers, reading Quran, you know,
guarding our ears, eyes, all of that, you know, these are all external type of Embadat.
Now, if I asked you, what do you think is essential for Istaqama?
Is it the internal or the external?
What would you say is essential for Istaqama?
Our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wa sallam in a hadith, he stated, Inna fil jasadi mudha.
Isa sulihat salahal jasadu kullu wa iza fasadat fasadal jasadu kullu.
Allah wahi al kalba.
Indeed, within the body, there is a lump of flesh.
Isa saluhat salahal jasadu kullu.
If it is set right,
If it is set straight, then the entire body will be set right.
But if it is corrupted, then the entire body will be corrupted.
Indeed, beware it is the heart.
So what we're learning from this hadith is that the master of the body isn't actually the mind.
Which sounds a bit strange because many people believe that the mind is what is in control.
Well, news flash.
It's actually your heart that is in control.
It's your heart that controls your mind.
Now what do I mean by that?
The type of heart that you have will control your thoughts.
It'll control your mind and eventually it'll control your actions.
So whatever your heart truly desires, your mind will think of ways to fulfill those desires.
And then the limbs will actually make it happen.
They will execute it.
You see?
So the heart is the king.
What the king wants needs to happen.
Who helps the king
figure out how to make it happen that's the wazir that's the mind right that's the brain and then there is the army which is the limbs that actually carry out and execute what the wazir comes up with for the king so the mind actually becomes a tool an instrument to execute whatever is in the heart and this is why our Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam he said if you take care of this lump of flesh which is the heart
Now everyone be clear that when I say the heart, I'm not talking about the physical heart, right?
I'm talking about the spiritual heart, the cult.
So if this heart is purified, when you take care of that heart, when you feed the heart, when you rectify the heart, then all your actions will automatically become pure.
But when the heart is corrupted, when it is starved, when it's not taken care of,
when it is deprived of its spiritual sustenance then the rest of the actions will just naturally get corrupted and what's really interesting that if you look at like if you see want to see this theory in its practical form let's look at the chronological theme of revelation
Just think about how the Quran was revealed.
What were the first verses to be revealed?
They were not about drinking alcohol and they were not about preventing people from committing fornication.
They were not about the rules of halal and haram.
The first verses to be revealed were all about building taqwa of Allah Subhanahu wa Ta'ala.
they were all about building an attachment with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala, about understanding the day of judgment, realizing and learning that we will be taken to account for our actions, that we're not just living in this life without a purpose like animals, that there is a purpose to Allah's tawhee, there is a purpose to Allah's oneness.
So the initial verses of Revelation
were about you know the day of judgment they were about retribution they were about loving Allah they were about understanding what Allah has done for us it was about understanding what Allah wants from us about life and death about you know basically who He is and what He wants why because all those initial verses of Revelation they were building a foundation for us
they were setting the foundation of his taqama.
So now if we go back to the example of the salah tree, Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala says in Suratul Ibrahim, when he gives the example of a good word, he says that a good word is like a good tree.
alam tara kaifadaraballahu mathalan kalimatin tayyibatin ka shajaratin tayyibatin asluha thaabit wa fara uha fissamaa
do you not see how Allah sets forth the example of a good word which is like a fruitful tree its roots are firmly fixed into the earth and its branches rise up to the sky so in other words its foundation is solid that's what the word Allah uses and then its branches rise up towards the sky see you can become elevated
Right, you can grow, you can get higher, you can force yourself into a path of spiritual elevation, but if you don't have solid roots, it's not gonna last long, and this is what happens with so many people that.
and this is something that I have struggled with myself so I can actually speak from experience that I can I have forced myself into the prayers fasting and this and that and I do it for a while and I push myself and I push myself and I just grit my teeth and I do it but doesn't last something happens and suddenly everything goes out the window and this was happening for a while until I finally understood these things because what I realized is that the taller a tree gets the deeper its roots have to go
So if you study the way Allah has designed a tree, you'll see that the taller it is, the more deep and wide its roots are spread within the earth.
In fact, even mountains we know have foundations, and the taller it is, the more it is grounded within the earth.
Everything, anything in existence, in order for it to be solid and firm and to have a taqama, it must have a solid foundation.
And so Allah is telling us, and even in the training that He gives us, He did not start out with the rules, He started out with building our foundation.
And this is why Suratul Fateha, which is essentially the summary of the entire Quran, right?
It's a description of what you are about to find in the remaining 113 surahs.
It begins, look how Surah Al-Fateha begins, by creating an understanding of who Allah is.
Alhamdulillahi Rabbil Alameen, Al-Rahmani Raheem, Maliki Aumideen.
These are all verses about knowing Allah, about setting this foundation.
And once this foundation is built,
which will naturally engender taqwa and tawakkul which is you know our reliance and trust in Allah only then we are taught to ask for the rules and guidance but look at the order of these verses right the beginning verses are designed to build a solid foundation
so that when the rules are revealed, we can just have a stakama.
You understand?
If we look at the example of the tree again, when a wind blows, if the roots of the tree are deep and they are firm within the ground, what happens to the tree?
Well, its leaves might move, the branches might shake and break, but the tree stays standing.
Right?
It's solid.
But what happens to a tree that does not have deep roots?
It easily gets knocked over.
And I believe that the problem with Islamic training these days is that we are raised in such a way that we just don't have solid roots.
Our training method is the rule shaming method.
It's this rule oriented or rule shaming method.
This is the method where you grow up as a kid and the only thing you are really taught about is haram and hellfire.
And the emphasis is on if you do haram, you will go to hellfire.
And that's how many of us were raised and that's how many of us are raising our children.
Well, it is true that there are things that are haram.
It is true that there is hellfire.
It is true that Allah has anger and wrath.
This is all true.
But why are children being taught that above His mercy?
Why are we not teaching our children that Allah is the most merciful?
And that even if you make a mistake, if you make a mistake and you repent, you can always try again.
Why is this not the message that is being taught?
And the answer, unfortunately, is because this is to control the behavior of the child.
So many of us use fear as this control mechanism.
The only problem is that this might have worked
maybe somewhat in my generation, more so in the previous generation, but in the new generation, it just backfires.
When we're using false fear or false shame, unhealthy shame to control someone's behavior, we're not building solid roots.
What we're building is avoidance.
Imagine that you grew up in a household where you're always being told, let's take police as an example, right?
You're always being told that you better watch out for the police.
They're going to throw you in jail.
Don't make a mistake.
You better not do this.
You better not do that because, you know, the police is going to catch you and they're going to throw you in jail.
They're going to punish you.
So you are basically taught to be afraid of the police.
Why?
Because police is made out to be this very wrathful and scary entity.
Now, if you grow up with this kind of training, years and years of this kind of material being fed to you, best case scenario, you will learn to avoid the police.
That's the best case scenario.
But will you want to be close to the police?
Will you want to be best friends with the police?
Will you confide your problems to the police?
Will you turn to the police for help when you're in trouble?
No, because you don't trust the police and you've been told that they're just there to punish you.
You see?
And so what's happening is that this type of training is not building Istakama.
It's not building any form of stability in our youth and in our own selves.
It's building avoidance.
So many people, when they are raised this way, when they grow up, they don't want to have anything to do with Allah.
They actually want to avoid Allah and religion completely.
Because they say, you know what, everything is haram, no matter what I do, I'm going to end up going to hell anyway.
Everything I do is wrong, so what's the point in trying?
You know, and to make it worse in our teachings and these, you know, there are some, I've heard someone say that, you know, if you don't do namaz this way and if you don't do ruku this way and such that your namaz will be thrown in your face.
I mean, this is, you know, a child making an effort to actually stand up for namaz.
and then you tell him that okay so everything I do is Haram and I'm going to get punished for it but the good things that I do are not good enough you tell me why should anyone come to a religion like that so what happens is that everybody starts avoiding religion and Allah together all together because it's backfiring
And the reason it's backfighting is because we are trying to grow this tree of Islam within ourselves and our children without creating any solid foundation.
So even miraculously if this tree sustains long enough to grow, it then is not able to survive the smallest earthquake, you see?
It cannot stand the smallest storm.
so we need to focus on building a solid foundation so that when life hits us because we are going to be shaken in life there's no doubt about that I mean look at the times we live in with all this these temptations around us these these desires going crazy right the tree this tree of Islam within our hearts it will be shaken from time to time we will be tested through trials
That's not something that should come as a surprise to anyone, right?
That is something that Allah clearly says in the Quran.
Do you really think that you will enter paradise without going through that which those who came before you went through?
they were struck with calamity they were struck with adversity they were they struggled and then they were shaken the word zulzilu in Arabic it actually comes from the same root as zilzal which means an earthquake so they were shaken like an earthquake and they were tried so much and they were shaken so much that even the messengers
And those with the messengers, they started asking, when will the help of Allah arrive?
Indeed, the help of Allah is near.
The help of Allah isn't just there.
It doesn't just exist as a concept.
It's there right now with you as you're going through the test.
Allah says that we are closer to you than your jugular vein.
And what's interesting about that, you know, a lot of people don't understand what that means.
That's the verse.
What does that mean?
It means that we are closer to you than your own consciousness.
See jugular vein, you cut the jugular vein, what's the first thing that the person loses?
Consciousness, right?
So what that means is that we
We know what you are about to think before you think it.
It's that kind of proximity.
So we are going to be shaken from time to time.
Now, how does a building withstand an earthquake?
Again, the answer all goes back to the type of foundation it has.
That is what will determine its estacama.
So the question we have to ask ourselves is what type of foundation do we have with Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala?
When I am tested through pain or through pleasure, will I be able to withstand it?
Will I be able to be firm on the straight path?
And if the honest answer to that is no, that means I need to work on my relationship with Allah, not work on the rules.
not try to increase, not try to increase my salat or my fasting and I need to first work on my relationship.
The rules, the actions will just follow.
And this is why scholars have said that the first verses that were revealed they did not say give up alcohol and give up fornication because people would have said you know we'll never give up those things and they would never have if it started with that because they had not yet built a foundation with Allah.
They had not yet built the roots.
So if you come to a person from the very start and you give them rules, they're just not going to follow it because it goes against what they want.
And that is the very mistake that many of us make with ourselves and with our children.
I made that with myself.
So we're not building a foundation, we're constantly throwing rules at them.
we're not talking about building an attachment with Allah we're not teaching them to love Allah we're not teaching them what it really means to put our reliance on Allah where is that being taught the only thing being taught to our children is that you know this is Haram that is Haram it's Haram if to eat this it's Haram to drink that it's Haram to dress like that it's Haram to say this I mean that's it right
and the problem with that method is that everything about Islam is being rejected and that is exactly what the scholars said right that if you start off with the rules if Allah had started off with the rules even with the companions these were the best people that existed but even they would have rejected the rules and this is why Allah did not start with the rules
I mean look at Juz' Ammah, right, the 30th chapter of Quran, it's basically Meccan, majority of the verses in that Juz were revealed in the initial stages of Islam, in the first 10 years of Islam.
Where do you find rules in that?
Do you find any rules?
Not really, it talks about Allah, it talks about His love, His mercy, it talks about the Day of Judgment, it talks about human beings, it talks about their relationships.
with themselves, among themselves, with Allah, it talks about, you know, human psychology, it talks about Taqwa, it talks about Tawakkul, it talks about retribution, it teaches about Jannah, it teaches about Jahannam, right, it focuses, you know, on all these things that are relationship building, it's all foundation building stuff in Juzammah.
Because if you want Istaqama, you have to build a foundation in the love of Allah.
See, this brings me to an interesting point about Taqwa, that when we generally talk about Taqwa, we think in terms of shame and fear.
Right?
And you might say, well, that is a good thing, isn't it?
I mean, what's wrong with fear?
Well, interestingly, today, psychologists, they are telling us that there is healthy fear and then there is unhealthy fear.
Okay, there is healthy fear and then there is unhealthy fear.
give you an example.
You know when you do something really bad and you're really scared of your parents or your loved ones finding out?
Sometimes what do we do?
Do you run to the parent or your loved one or do you run away from them?
You run away from them and you hide, right?
So there's basically two ways to respond when you hurt someone or when you make a mistake.
So imagine that you just hurt your closest friend or you hurt your spouse.
There are some people who feel so bad about it, so ashamed about it, what they do is that they hide.
They try to avoid the person.
They try to hide from the issue.
They try to avoid the conversation.
They distance themselves from the person, right?
Now is that a healthy way to deal with it?
Does that actually solve the problem or does it make it worse?
It makes it worse.
And this is exactly what we do with Allah.
When many of us feel like we've made a mistake and we're so ashamed, instead of going towards Allah, we run away from Him.
We try to hide.
so we don't want to pray anymore because you know we feel so ashamed and we don't want to talk about Allah we don't want to talk about religion because it makes us feel ashamed but then what's a healthier way to deal with this when you've hurt someone what's the healthiest way to fix it to go to the person and what apologize
to go to the person and say, I'm sorry, I regret it.
I admit it.
I made a mistake.
I'm going to try to do better.
Give me another chance.
I will try to do better.
And if I fail, I will try again.
And I will try again.
That is astaghfar.
That is tauba.
That is what we're supposed to do.
Because that is healthy fear.
that is the healthy response when you make a mistake that instead of trying to hide from Allah instead of saying you know I just don't want to do anything with religion I want nothing to do with God I'm not even gonna try I'm not gonna pray because you know I've committed so many sins you know I just feel so ashamed to face Allah that's an unhealthy type of shame
But taqwa is not unhealthy fear.
It is not unhealthy shame.
It is healthy fear.
It is the kind of healthy shame that will help you try to stay away from what displeases or what angers Allah.
And when you do what angers Allah, you will rush to apologize and you will rush to repent.
You will try to make things better.
and the reason I'm mentioning all of this is because I feel what's happening is that we are just feeding the wrong kind of fear and shame because you know when you talk about Allah or you think about Allah like a scary policeman I mean you're encouraging yourself you're encouraging your children and the people around you to actually avoid Allah you're subconsciously teaching them to run away from Allah not to run towards him
not to apologize, to fix it.
So healthy fear will motivate us to get closer to Allah and repent.
Unhealthy shame will make us run away from Allah and it'll make us avoid Him out of shame.
So in order for us to have this ability to stay firm on our Iman, to have istaqama on the Sarat al-Mustaqeen,
We all need to learn to develop this healthy fear of Allah, which is called Taqwa.
Now how do we do that?
How do we build healthy fear?
You know what the seed of healthy fear is?
What the seed of Taqwa is?
This is interesting.
Actually, let me put it this way.
Let's back up.
What's the seed to unhealthy shame?
We know that a seed is the essence, right?
It's the seed that grows into a tree.
But it all starts at the seed level.
So if you want to address something, we should always look at the root cause, right?
The seed.
Now, if you look at the seed of unhealthy shame, you know what it is?
It's thinking that you are supposed to be perfect.
It's this myth of perfection that lies at the root of our problems.
It is when you're taught and you start believing that you're actually supposed to be perfect.
And if you believe that, then you will react with unhealthy shame when you make a mistake.
Why?
Because you feel like I was supposed to be perfect.
And I'm not perfect and I'm so ashamed of myself, I'm not even going to try anymore because this is too hard.
So what that does is it leads us to despair.
But what was the root cause?
What was the seed that you thought that you were supposed to be perfect?
Because that's what you were taught by your family, your teachers, your culture, whatever.
Now let's go to the root or the seed of healthy Taqwa.
and healthy Astaghfar and healthy Tauba, you know, going back to Allah.
Do you know what the root is?
Knowing, understanding that all human beings will make mistakes.
It's actually the opposite.
It is realizing that the human being is imperfect.
Understanding that we have been created as imperfect human beings.
when you know that when you understand that then you can easily respond with repentance because you know that you're human and so you messed up okay I messed up I screwed up I screwed up big time but I'm gonna fix it I'm gonna try and repent I'll try again I'll try harder
Even if I make the same mistake over and over and over again and I keep repenting over and over and over again, I will not give up trying to do better.
That is the essence of Tauba.
Imperfect human beings trying to take one tiny step towards perfection.
That's what we are trying.
Trying to make tomorrow better than yesterday.
That's what we are supposed to do.
The Prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam, he said, All children of Adam will make mistakes, but the best of them are the ones who repent.
So we have to let go of this crazy myth of perfection because it's the root cause of so many of our problems.
it is the reason why we keep you know falling into despair because if you're told you're supposed to be perfect and you end up realizing that you're not perfect or you cannot be perfect or it's just too difficult to be perfect that is frustrating that is irritating but when you understand that we are created with this you know
this design of being imperfect.
How can you go against the divine design?
Tell me that.
Just tell me that.
How can you go against the divine design?
How can anyone do that?
Allah says that He created us imperfect.
Look at the descriptions of human beings in the Quran.
I mean seriously.
This like you know clay, pottery clay.
We created man weak.
We made him impatient.
Indeed man has been created anxious.
Look at, I mean these are some descriptions of human being in the Quran.
Weak, built from filthy liquid, hasty, impatient, anxious.
So how can we go against that?
It's impossible.
And when you try to go against that, you will end up hitting with despair.
But then Allah he balances out our weakness by telling us, oh my servants, my servants, my beloved servants.
What type of servants who have transgressed completely against their soul by their constant sins?
do not despair of the mercy of Allah you know when we commit sins okay everybody get this straight when we commit sins when we do something that has been forbidden we are not hurting Allah just be very clear about that when we do something good we're not doing any favors to Allah when we do something bad we're not hurting Allah
we're only hurting ourselves because we cannot wrong Allah right we cannot hurt Allah we cannot take anything away from Allah his kingdom is infinite everybody be very clear about that and by doing anything good we're not doing him any kind of favors so you know by doing when Allah forbids us from something it's for our own benefit it's for the benefit of our spirituality it's for us to move along the Surat Al-Mustaqim
So by doing wrong, by committing what is forbidden, we are only hurting our own souls.
So be very clear about that.
You know, it's like if you drink poison, are you hurting yourself or the doctor?
The doctor is telling you don't drink poison because the doctor understands that what you're drinking is poison.
You're drinking it because it tastes good.
It feels good.
It makes you high.
But if you drink that poison, are you essentially hurting yourself or the doctor?
If you refuse then to take the medicine, the antidote for that poison, are you hurting yourself or are you hurting the doctor?
You're hurting yourself.
So just realize that Allah is not the one that we are wronging by committing a sin.
We are hurting none other than our own souls.
So Allah says,
tell my slaves my beloved slaves the ones that I have created with love and compassion and these people who are hurting themselves by doing wrong who are transgressing against their own selves who are transgressing against their own souls do not despair in the mercy of Allah Allah is telling us not to despair
but many of us we despair because we have this wrong concept about ourselves and this wrong concept about Allah our egos just cannot bear the fact that we are not perfect so we we think of ourselves as you know that I'm supposed to be perfect I better be perfect and if I'm not perfect then I'm worthless so we all have this you know this all or none mindset I mean
I either have to be an angel otherwise I am going to be the devil.
This is something I thought only I used to struggle with but I found out that this is very common because I used to always think like that.
There's no way I can be good, there's no way I can be an angel but yeah I can be a devil that comes easier to me so I'm just going to go that way.
In my head it was all black or white but we have to stop that.
It changed my life when I
stop thinking like that you know Bani Adam is not one or the other the children of Adam Bani Adam were not angels and were not a devil a believer is actually someone who is flawed contrary to all everything that we've been taught so far a believer is actually someone who is flawed but who continually strives to repent
and who tries really hard to get it right who doesn't give up who constantly strives to get back up after he falls who never gives up that is a believer that is a moment not somebody who is flawless this is why the prophet said that all children of Adam will make mistakes but the best are those who repent
Letting go of this false sense of perfection will allow us this ability to get back up when we fall.
And you want to hear something else that's really counterintuitive?
Shaitan feeds off this false sense of perfection.
I mean, Shaitan really does a number with it.
He uses it as a weapon against us.
You know how?
When you make a mistake or when I make a mistake, He'll come to us and He'll say, Look at you.
How shameful is you?
You're gonna pray now after you did this?
What kind of a terrible person are you?
Do you not have any shame?
Look what a hypocrite you are.
Just look at you.
Now you're gonna stand before Allah after doing this.
He's not even gonna look at you.
Who would look at you?
Would you look at somebody else who did that to you?
Would you be merciful on somebody who did something like that to you?
Of course not.
So then if you wouldn't be merciful towards somebody like that, then why do you expect Allah to be merciful to you?
You don't deserve His mercy.
You don't deserve His love.
Does that sound familiar?
These kind of thoughts?
This is how Shaitaan uses this tool of false perfection against us.
He'll put us through this unhealthy shame.
He'll drag our face through this unhealthy fear and shame and then when we're done shaming ourselves and bashing ourselves up, then He'll come to us from a different angle and He'll say, Do you really want to believe in a God who puts you through this mental torture?
I mean, think about it.
Allah created you as imperfect human being and He's now demanding perfection of you.
What kind of a horrible master is this?
I mean, what kind of ridiculous religion is this?
Look at the contradiction in it.
Just leave it, right?
Look how Shaitaan works, right?
He's the one who put us through this unhealthy shame, then he comes at us from a different angle.
How could Allah do this to you?
How could He put that alcohol in your presence?
Didn't he know that you're weak in the Quran.
He says that he knows everything.
He says he's closer than your jugular vein He knew that you would drink that alcohol.
Why did he put it in your presence?
Whose fault is it?
Why would he do that to you?
It's not your fault you drank that alcohol.
It's Allah's fault clearly look at that.
It's just logic I Mean look at this religion how stupid is that you see
and you know what we do we say you know what that makes perfect logical sense if really Allah you know he should have known better so you know what screw religion but if we realize that we are not perfect and that we were never created to be perfect
Then when Shaitaan comes to us in these ways, and he gives us all these brilliant ideas, we say, You know what?
Thank you for that.
Yes, I know I made a mistake, but my Allah is Most Merciful.
My Allah is not like me.
My Allah, I may not forgive another person if he does something wrong to me.
I may not forgive this other person if he does it again.
I will definitely not forgive him if he does it again and again and again, the same thing.
but I am not Allah but my Allah is not like me my Allah is way more merciful than I can ever be than all of humanity combined can ever be because my Allah is He is the most forgiving He will forgive me if I try again and even if I fail after that and if I repent again He will forgive me again
but I will keep on trying until I get it right that's what Allah wants us to have hope in his mercy there's this beautiful hadith of Rasulallah in which it's a hadith of Qudsi in which Allah is talking to us through the prophet and he said Allah says ya ibn Adam
Allah says, O son of Adam, as long as you call upon me and ask of me, I shall forgive you for what you have done and I will not even care about it.
I won't even care what you did.
That's how easily I will forgive you.
Yabno Adam, lau balaka zunoobu ka ananis samayi somastaghfartani ghafartulak O son of Adam, were your sins so big, so many to reach the clouds of the sky and were you to then ask forgiveness of me, ghafartulak I would instantly forgive you.
I don't have time to get into linguistics of this but
It's so beautiful.
.
Instantly forgive you.
Yabnu Adam, inna ka lau ataytani bikurabil ardi khataya summa lakitani la tushiriku bishaya la ataytu ka bikurabi ha maqfirah.
O son of Adam, were you to come to Me with sins as great as this earth?
and were you then to face Me, ascribing no partnership with Me, I would bring you forgiveness as great as your sin is.
That's who Allah is.
I mean, according to this hadith, Allah says that if someone goes to Allah with sins that fills the area between the heavens and the earth, I mean, do you know how much that area is?
I mean, think about it.
the area between the earth and the sky filled with sins.
Who has that many sins?
That's a lot of sins, right?
That's a lot.
And what Allah is saying that if anyone comes to Him with sins filling the area between the heaven and the earth and then they sincerely repent to Him, Allah will give them forgiveness which is as big or more.
So that is who Allah is.
He is not a policeman who is waiting to throw us in jail.
He is the most merciful.
But the problem is that we are not teaching His mercy.
We're just teaching His wrath.
We're not teaching any attachment to Allah.
We're just teaching rules.
We're not talking about the roots, we're talking about the leaves and the branches.
You have to eat like this, you have to dress like this, you have to walk like this, you have to eat, sleep and spit like this.
I mean this is allowed, this is not, you know, these micro nutrients, this micro ingredient is not halal within the pizza.
I mean, it's kind of halal, but it's not 100.
I've actually seen a bottle of water that says halal certified on it.
A bottle of water that says halal certified on it.
It's water.
*** **** it.
I mean, this is missing the fruit, what do we call it, the forest for the trees, right?
This is it.
This is missing the forest for a leaf on a tree.
We're not focusing on the roots.
So what ends up happening is we end up creating either this aversion and this hatred for religion, you know, completely abandoning it, or then there is this external shell, this lifeless shell of Ibadah that just crumbles to the ground with the first trial.
I mean, don't get me wrong, I do not belittle the importance of the outer worship.
Of course, it's a combination of both things.
That's how I started by saying that Deen is the outer worship coupled with the inner worship.
That's why I began with that, right?
It's both Amanu and Amila Salihat.
But what I'm saying is that you cannot do one and not the other.
The problem what I'm saying is that many of us are focusing only on the outer aspects and if you just focus on the outer, it's like growing a tree without roots.
So when the wind comes, it'll just knock it down.
We all need to have solid roots, which is the relationship with Allah.
So, how do we build these roots practically?
First, I told you we remove this myth of human perfection from our minds we have to set a different understanding.
that we as human beings, we are not perfect, we were not created to be perfect and a true believer is somebody who acknowledges that imperfection and then takes the step to better himself.
So we are created as human beings to keep repenting and keep trying again and take small tiny steps every day towards that perfection, which we may or we may never achieve, which is fine.
But at least we're walking in the right direction.
We're not walking in the opposite direction.
I mean, can you imagine a child that is learning to walk for the first time, this child, right?
He's learning to walk and he falls down and he says, you know what?
I'm just going to stop trying.
This is too hard.
I'm just going to sit here and that's it.
I'm never going to walk.
That child will never learn how to walk.
Can you imagine a person driving and the moment he makes a wrong turn, they just switch off their car.
You know, they put it in park and they just say, you know what, forget it.
I'm not going to drive.
This whole car is stupid.
This whole route is stupid.
I'm done.
That's it.
I made a wrong turn.
Imagine, okay, imagine your GPS saying you made a wrong turn.
Sorry, right?
You turn left instead of right and your GPS goes, you know what?
You made a wrong turn.
Just stop trying.
I'm not giving you any directions.
Turn off the car.
Your trip is over.
Does the GPS do that?
No.
What does it do?
It does something completely different.
What does it say?
Recalculating, rerouting.
What is that in Arabic?
That's Tauba.
That's actually literally Tauba because Tauba means to return, return.
Tauba is our internal mechanism rerouting us back to Allah.
That's the process of Astaghfar.
The word Tauba in Arabic literally means to turn around and return.
How many times does the GPS of your car reroute you?
Just once?
If you take several wrong turns, what does the GPS say?
You know what?
You're an idiot.
It's pointless trying to give you directions.
You just keep making the same wrong turns.
I'm not going to guide you anymore.
You know, does the GPS do that?
No, it keeps rerouting you.
How many times?
Millions, billions of times if it has to.
Infinite number of times.
Tell me I'm wrong.
A GPS
A man-made machine is capable of doing that.
You think Allah cannot do that?
Subhanallah.
So we have to change the way we think.
We have to be able to get back up after we fall.
We have to learn to repent and we have to learn to keep going and keep trying.
That is the first thing for Istaqama.
Now what we can do to develop this foundation
is actually very simple.
It's a simple three ingredient recipe.
The first is salat.
That's like the oxygen of the heart.
That is where we connect with Allah.
That's where we have that communication with Allah.
That's where we go to the person we've wronged and we say sorry.
It's what keeps us spiritually, psychologically and mentally connected with Allah.
so no matter what you do even if you're doing the worst things possible don't ignore your prayers keep getting there keep connecting if you can do five do three can do three do two do one at least try to pray once a day and then rejoice in that prayer be really happy and proud of that prayer I mean no matter how distracted or imperfect you think it was you know what if you did a fast and furious kind of prayer
This is another problem we face, that again stems from this myth of perfection.
If I asked you to list out for me all your sins and all your mistakes that you committed today, you'll probably be able to give me a long list.
But if I asked you to list out for me all your good deeds of the day, I bet you're going to struggle with that.
Can I write this down?
Is it good enough?
Does that count?
First of all, you won't even remember half the things you did.
Because we don't appreciate the good that we do as much as we beat ourselves over the wrong that we do.
You see?
So from now on, every good deed that you do, from tasting that salt before, if you remember to taste that salt before your food, to wearing your topi, to, I don't know, to smiling at someone, every little thing.
I want you to be grateful for that I want you to acknowledge it I want you to be happy about it I want you to remember Allah when you do that I want you to you know make the angels write that in your book by saying Alhamdulillah keep reminding yourself of Allah after every good deed and then feel really happy about it and really proud about it just just for remembering to say Bismillah before something
you know from from saying Bismillah to saving somebody's life and everything in between I want you to be happy and rejoice in every good deed that you do you do you did a Salat you did one Salat just the first and you were Amazon shopping while you were doing that you know what you did Namaz you did Salat you stood up to remember Allah you dropped whatever you were doing and you connected with Allah be happy about that
Try to do better next time, but be happy.
Don't crap on what you did.
Don't discredit the effort that you made.
This is how you build relationship with Allah, slowly, small chunks, by thinking about Him, by remembering Him, consciously realizing that this is something you're actually doing to please Him every time you do it.
So be easy on yourselves.
Enjoy what you're doing.
Enjoy the good that you are doing to make Allah happy.
That's the first.
Second is du'a, the daily , the remembrance of Allah through supplications.
That's the GPS rerouting us.
And the third is the recitation and understanding of Quran.
I mean, you have to stay connected to it daily, even if one verse a day, I don't care.
if you do this daily and you understand it and you're consistent with it you will build istiqama you will build this resilience on the straight path this saratul mustaqeen I mean these are things that have really really helped me in life and I really hope it'll do the same for you wa akharuda'waan alhamdulillahi wa bilalamin was salatu was salam wa ala rasul he saydana muhammadan khatimin nabiin was sayedul mursaleen wa ala akhi wa wasi yalibnabi taaliba shrafil wasiyin wa alal aimmatimin zuriyatima taibinatahin wa salim alihi majma'in al fateen